back up my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching
you know I'm not good as chin snitch hat
from prison today
yes obviously different let's obviously
that crazy hat oh that shank redemption
shank redemption can you get us stuff
into ourselves yeah we will you throw a
picture of chin in there to camp
whenever you post a little bit of that
moment because that is shinjang for them
either start [ __ ] skateboarding for
us or sneaker strokes what seek us some
[ __ ] shanks yeah
dude they're just buzz oh you got a new
battery in yours oh I don't know it's
pretty high that's a little better get
it back that's pretty much it
nobody fix has a new shelf there's a
loan already I prayed about it dude you
you know what you look different you're
dressing different really I saw a
picture of you on Stanford's campus
oh yeah we're just new questions okay
the [ __ ] were you doing Stanford campus
should not be allowed on my campus this
Tiger Woods grounds oh look they shall
weep is it what shall we yeah bro well
maybe a guy named ed McCaffrey John
Elway Donnie McCaffrey dude nobody here
ever heard about Donnie McCaffrey dude
Sun toppers the other third that third
McCaffrey but I worked at the uh in the
in the McCaffrey tyria and nobody he
wasn't doing any athletic making McRib
oh isn't there making mcribs and bugging
me you know yeah just huffing off taking
Huff's a hit hits off of those off of
puddin can what were you doing there
that dude I went to Stanford a friend of
mine this man Harrison Phillips he plays
for the Buffalo Bills Bills mafia
shallots of bills mafia and he played D
plays defensive tackle first of all
white guy playing defensive tackle big
boy yeah you should get three points for
even having one of those players on your
team
I agree at the beginning of the game you
should you should get at least get a few
wins ahead of everybody I filled with
white defensive tackle Wow America you
know come on Oprah but you're damn right
Buffalo draft to them yeah close like
Utah Jazz they go down they go white
dude we'll take him we'll take him
one thing I learned while I was there on
on the
they only have 7,000 undergrad students
at Stanford and then they have 7,000
post-grad students on campus at the same
time did you crazy did you think you got
a little smarter just being around them
Oh DJ in the water
well people kept looking at me strange
you know and then I'll be like I'm just
looking for some books and the people
are like oh okay you know like that
makes sense yeah that's fine cuz you
look different I feel like you might be
a little smart really I bet they were
looking at you like who the [ __ ] let
this pedophile on the campus I did a
whole hold on to a stack of books for
someone who's going down at like a
handicap ramp for a minute young lady I
bet - it could have been either man they
don't like you to say man or woman
they're on campus kids are there to
study a human yeah they have emergency
libraries if you're scared or something
dude you can hit a button or like still
have like a little branch on a tree and
you kind of pull it in a couple of books
or pockets yes so did call me down like
oh god yeah yeah it was crazy man one
guy got real nervous uh we gave some guy
ride across campus and he accuses a
hazing because the music was too loud in
the car you guys growing too fast rying
to solve the world's problems you
imagine going to school there reading
books get it sucked yeah it's great no
yeah right dude how many would if you
had a names for books that you've read
what are they
oh I'm reading right now I'm dying up
here in the book of The Comedy Store
okay I read a lot of books I know you do
yeah I'm not saying that you're saying
books in general yeah well I'm dying up
here born standing up sick in the head
that's not a book there's you can hedge
on Aptos it is yeah oh God teach you how
to be a [ __ ] thought Apatow yeah later
Wow
I would never cast him in an episode of
this podcast that's for damn sure I'm
gonna be able to go dude you guys didn't
get this guy in the king of the stain
bro are you blot if you're blind listen
no hey yeah we don't have any guests
what are you talking about get this guy
I'm king of the stain like yeah have you
ever seen a gasps no are you blind
well what are you doing what are you
doing yeah some kid the other day I was
like y'all gonna get Zion Williamson on
King in the stage oh let me call him I
call him up and get him on it let me rip
Sian's [ __ ] drip what feel real quick
yeah some of the stuff we get is crazy
but that's what I did I went to Stanford
dude I was in San Jose we had eight
Oh's man bro crazy bro [ __ ] touch me
dude even though you're rich now rich
what are you talking about this shirt is
from twillerbee one of our sponsors
oh you got that at Stanford I'll get
that books or at Stanford I heard they
sell polos and books
dude the bookstores huge or people
camping in there there were people there
families had been in there you know
there were families just walking around
some kid was washing his head made like
a little like a like a kind of like a
campsite and they were washing up dude I
hope that uh like scheme still going on
so I can pay for my son and go to
Stanford Oh at Stanford yeah hopefully
everyone doesn't snitch on everyone if I
could put my son into Stanford for 200
G's doing [ __ ] bro you want to grow
for $40 you can get a look in the
Louisiana State University so that's a
hard pass that's what I'm talking about
oh come on bro to 20s dude yeah it's not
bad yeah now you're Susanna Tiger that
dude
you drop your smarter 400 bro let me
tell you this if your son I don't know
how you gonna do it ends up with some
type of strong capability okay actually
athletic capability could have he's
afraid that's the one gift you probably
have give my password hopefully has his
mom's kind of friendly Jean yeah and
then he has your ability yeah the kind
Tiger broke he will be like if he play
for the Tigers Thai bro it would be
unprecedent or Missouri we're going
sizzler oh dude you're gonna own a
sizzler yeah dude you're right the oh
and you've yeah and if you're gonna get
paid to play man LSU that's where
they're doing that at right now so every
all those SEC schools pay very well I
heard very well that you won't pay for a
McNugget that's what I remember being
Aaron one of the basketball players I
was like are they paying you all he said
look man I ain't paid for a mac nugget
in two years
yeah I mean that's how they do it that's
ICC keeps a McRib is back year-round
down the McRib dude everybody got some
McCrea dams so what about you man where
were you at this weekend oh Milwaukee
hockey I wanna be uh different yeah
different I thought it was an all-white
city and I've been actually educated
that's actually one the most diverse
cities a lot of Indians there are Dean's
they call them nope a lot of
african-americans mainly half a
yeah yeah actually someone sent me
statistics more african-americans in
Chicago oh I found surprising pretty
cool I had no idea that walk I brought
Derrick Poston who's a hilarious
comedian and he's mixed - he's at Cafe
de Gaulle or yeah he's a little Colin or
some EA's Carl man yeah he might be a is
caramel and then a sauna mod who's also
a comedy store door guy
so it was a we're cultural oh yeah you
got sound cultural as hell yeah dude and
I look Mexican so we got weird looks
that foster you guys are gonna get am
foster family yeah we've done movie four
brothers yeah yeah that would be your
mass so he was dope though I was in San
Jose that city's diverse man diverse
with Asian bro the Malaysians in the
world in San Jose bro all types - man
they're not everything Japanese and your
SOI brother they had a sabe
oh dude bulgogi did you know I'm Bobo
what's that juice called you over boba
boba yeah juice but no bogeys actual
creamy oh it is yeah cream meat curry
Meatwad who's walking around there they
got their Wagyu it was wild man yeah and
they Hawk you not so much bro dude the
Mexican national soccer team will stay
in a motel really so there was all types
of like football fans outside like
beating drums I mean it was insane like
their their national team bro it was
crazy man
yeah it was kidding me dude well I mean
yeah there's a good time for all I it
was good yeah I think it was a good time
for all I mean I I'm shooting the
opening of my comedy special this or I
think next week oh yeah shootin open for
oh good thanks brother your first one
what's gonna be called oh wait I know
what it is
[Music]
watch me watch me try again let me try
the hole I know what it is it is CT
included let me see uh let's do you
think you can dance is that great shot
Deacon dance comedy special yeah
hilarious oh no the next closer
because you dancing music on a stage Oh
wide open with that bro
you'd be surprised maybe surprised yeah
alright man let's get on this show you
guys my new SIM card events yes
yeah sure chin this when you get out of
here bro Brooks was here this is a
friend as you know anecca meritorious i
got it a small hat but chance on you did
it less than five hours
oh hi this is friend what the sisters
get th it ladies
believe me she's a high school student
and she's the second girl ever to win
the McDonald's all-american dunk
contests it's an all women's dunk
contest believe it is but I don't know
pierce my dick than watch a woman's all
dunk contest is it an eight-foot rim
that's the thing it doesn't make sense
this article doesn't say anything about
guys being in it but if it's only the
second person ever that's a girl it just
has to be open to every female dunk
contest is called layups row it first of
all I think is what it's called right I
mean first of all why are they making
women dunk for [ __ ] McDonald's yeah
well this is talk about the me to missus
axis man is on an eight-foot rim chairs
at 10:00 there's no way it's 10 foot in
the other it's a regular high school
really [ __ ] she jumped over the rim bro
look she got mugged afternoon are you
sure that's a 10-foot rims it whatever
high school steroids
whoever high school rim is she's 6-1
first of all taking a grandmother's name
okay that's ran friend and dunking is
about the most G thing you can do okay
you know who's who's Duncan next s tell
you know what I'm saying
who's Duncan next Barbara good I'm
saying yeah Gertz I can i looped a Groot
Groot Richard Wow
Britney can't remember a word he just
said I don't like some of the I don't
think is to make women don't from
McDonald's I think they should be able
to be served no matter what
that's what my thoughts are you know I
in order for them to get breakfast all
day they have to dunk first oh no that's
fair I think's fair yeah I think
hashbrowns yeah
Oh put them on a McGriddle drunk [ __ ]
you better McFly dude I love the idea of
dunking from McDonald's put now I want
it I want a 10-foot ran out front and
and you dunk out there and then you get
the snack that you want I like that now
I'll do some [ __ ] from McCrea now how
tall are you though because she's
shorter than you and she can dunk i
watchin Doug can you really yeah I can
Wow look I've never seen girls dunk like
this ever has anyone in here it makes me
feel something going on forever I feel
old now no no no no there's only uh a
couple women have done it they had a
woman at LSU they had a woman no Leslie
Jones is in the comedian does she looks
like she could dunk down I know I
thought and she don't yeah that's sure
dear I could see that Wow
Fran turns out there was men too in this
competition and the woman beat them
because she got perfect scores all four
would see that I didn't like because I
don't think that just because that's
what I don't like sometimes just because
it's a dunk you get the ten dude here's
the thing though the dog the second dog
dude any you know was that a dog wasn't
it a dunk she became the second favorite
player to win the dunk contest so it's
men and women are competing and I picked
a woman yeah
Candace Parker won before the 2004 you
ever seen Candace Park oh yeah she can
get a candy park park beautiful but once
you get to the WNBA it's like watching
every every time I turn the game on it's
like Oh everybody's Latrell Sprewell
that's the vibe I get it's like he's
playing everyone I'd rather what Co try
and read a book then watch [ __ ] WNBA
okay well I've definitely read way more
books than you brother bro who you lying
to do do your lighting everybody round
not even gonna call it okay your mom
your mom's home reading doesn't yeah
your mom gave you just the cliffnotes
you thought they were novels at the time
bro some of the cliffnotes very long
they are too long very ugly few me
cliffnotes shorten them up but shorten
them up cliffnotes dude I'm gonna jump
off a cliff [ __ ] you cliff yeah how
about that Chris a terribie
you [ __ ] tighten it up you make it
easier the Bible cliffnotes make it easy
all right let's keep moving man
launching all right the biggest news
jussie Smollett all of his criminal
criminal charges were dropped by the
Cook County this is Chicago being like
dude we have 70 dudes dying every minute
on the south side we have way bigger
[ __ ] to worry about but also Jesse said
here's a hundred K y'all end me off
Chicago went cool get the [ __ ] out of
our city yeah I mean I think there's a
lot of this there's been all kind of
stuff at this over the decades you know
a lot of guys get off and this and a lot
of different racial crimes on both sides
of the net and just he playing every
side of the net he's black white gay
Muslim gay not gay make America don't
make America pick us yeah he's just
taking a nice standing up yeah dude he's
in a wheelchair every time you look at
this guy he's got a different thing
going on he tried to hire Atticus Finch
as his [ __ ] attorney this guy's out
of his mind man he's crazy lost his
career to I don't know if he lost his
career Empire was like we're all set all
I think it's just a shame I think he has
an ego problem and I hope that he finds
some way to heal it I don't know what
he's gonna do
but he I think I just hope that he you
know that he helps figure that out for
him because it looks like he's still
riding his lies but that hundred grain
you put your money where your mouth is
and he paid that hundred grand to get
out of there good deal yeah oh jeez they
gave him a good deal I think Chicago's
like get this Hollywood [ __ ] out of our
city I think we got way bigger fish to
fry yeah get the [ __ ] buddy down here
bro yeah we got the winner it's [ __ ]
terrible yeah Kanye won't shut the [ __ ]
up the hole suck all the bulls are bad
well he's trying to suck dudes off they
just can't have it bro yeah he can't
meet a man at a subway like look man
2:00 in the morning yeah I run to anyone
at Subway doing one I should sue my
getting sucked somebody's definitely
vacuuming you know just you don't
deserve any more of our chatter no all
right Papa John's the new face of Papa
John's is gonna be Shaquille O'Neal Dan
as their board member I'll tell you what
the worst pizza in the world
I love Shaq G where's pizza if you give
me Pizza Hut which we've gone over great
facility they got the tight Pizza Hut
dome but hands are not the pants you're
right brother deep-dish
today Stanford okay so yeah Pizza Hut we
love the setup of it Domino's oh my god
with extra sauce
brilliant Papa John's get the [ __ ] in my
face Papa Murphy's Ewing and that's
[ __ ] first of all pop him review as a
stepfather should be stepfather Murphy's
and he also worked at the church so you
know what I'm saying boy it's that
that's the slice that I reach down and
touch you nuts why you lighting a candle
you know what I'm saying this bro let's
don't deny that puppet yawns all it is
it's basically just a piece of bread
that serves you two banana peppers
that's all it is it's like crazy bread
don't call don't tell tell us crazy
breads [ __ ] pizza yes I can't you
just paid $19 for two peppers and some
bad bread underneath it dude a lot of
times I'll eat the peppers and disclose
the box
me too I just the peppers I feel pretty
good about myself too and now Papa John
the original Papa John was throwing the
N word around yeah but everybody's he
did it on a conference call though
that's what you know your narcissistic
anyone gets off that phone like dude I
recorded that everybody n-bombs talking
about cheese and parmesan yeah ro
everybody knows if you're gonna use the
M word you use it one-on-one with
somebody you know what I'm sayin
conference cultural conference call
goddamn broke me some pizza dropping him
bomb I mean now if you put also if there
was a dope-ass pizza place in an urban
neighborhood and they were throwing the
N bomb out there with every pie I might
go get one you know like if they called
me the n-word I grabbed a pilot I'll
come back tomorrow dude there's a place
in a Chicago called Mel
you know mr. weenies or something and
you go over there and they have a couple
of um unique women in the back and
they'll call you all types of name Wow I
like that oh they'll call you the guy
like get that actor Oh get that weeny
little and they use the f-word
you know [ __ ] for Joe you know - ah oh
right when you pick it up you're like oh
we got there wavy you know damn yeah I
like that and they will call you every
name there's a there's a place that
thing is called Wiener circle that's
what I like
and not to be completed not to be
confused with the Schenley Park Golf
Course up there in Pittsburgh where men
drive around and meet each other out
there by that sand trap yeah ain't the
same thing we need so get a nice deep
dish maybe a Sicilian slice you know I'm
saying you there's a place in LA can go
and they just thought you get a mixtape
to audition to make tape and the
dropping embalm for you oh I like to
deal man
well you know look if there's no racism
in the air man then the food ain't that
good and I've always said hey what's
next chin this homeless dude from West
Palm Beach oh [ __ ] it offered to that
kinda looks like don flamenco from Mike
Tyson's punch-out the guy looks like me
okay
forty years can we bring up a Don
flamingo really quick he does look like
him if Don flamingo got weight older and
did a lot of blow bring it up chin I'm
gonna make I'm gonna make you build a
library in the basement make you write
notes so we get a librarian okay there
we go right there he does look like good
reference bro thank you very much it's
really really paying off man thank you
miss the water man I drank two gallons
right out of the [ __ ] I gots to out
of the water fountain I was there and I
just start licking the kid oh dude I was
about to steal a pint of blood from one
little fella I just suck his neck yeah
vamp stamp that vant get that Stanford
blood what are you trying to say [ __ ]
it's a what I'm sayin this guy actually
offered to pay $500 to have sex with a
few people okay
he gave me the money me they said one or
more there was like four people who was
talking to you so they said at least one
person shows up here's the 500 bucks
have sex like a lot of money to me
nowadays in hot though must have been
four five hundo 500 so you had a
professional she didn't show up we
called the cops
they're just regular people yeah it's
America bro anything over $275 you you
know you usually kind of get what you
pay for visually yeah if you're looking
at JPEGs and if you're on Adult Friend
search yeah I found the back page and
you're looking to you know land some
nice tail for 275 you got your goddamn
line you know I'm saying yeah and you
can't look I've bought it I've gotten on
those sites high on drugs and try to
barter with people you know how to save
$30 here $25 here and it's worth they
get pissed dude that's like nickel and
diming a tattoo artist when you pay for
you don't want to do that with a puff or
a professional I'm not trying to
negotiate I said if it's $1,000 and
he agrees to 200 she ain't coming
looking like $1,000 ho
$80 one time has somebody drove by and
shot all the windows out in the front of
my apartment and right now and made me
venmo I'm dude and I've been modem fast
bro you know cuz I only had a couple
more windows on the back side of my
place man I was like I gotta [ __ ] have
some glasses else but this guy you mean
being American so he paid hardcore what
happened change it we got did they
arrested him showed us that they took
his money so of course the police
arrested for soliciting prostitution and
he was able to post bail which sounds
weird too cuz he's homeless
I guess he's almost Palm Beach Florida
no one's homeless you ever been in Palm
Beach well it's be so beautiful outdoors
that if you're just means you don't have
a [ __ ] six bedroom house yeah almost
means you just don't feel like looking
up at the sky beautiful there yeah it's
beautiful everybody's a you know I mean
that's [ __ ] this poor guy though
that's [ __ ] poor guys mother nature's
taint dude Florida beautiful area here's
an ad from the king of the state Robin
Hood is an investing app that lets you
buy and sell ETFs options and kryptos
all commission free while other
brokerages charged up to ten dollars for
every trade Robin Hood doesn't charge
any Commission fees Theo so he can trade
stocks and keep all of your money
plus there's in a no-account minimum
deposit needed to get started so you can
start investing at any level it's so
simple that design Robin Hood makes
investing easy for newcomers and your
experts Oh X purtz you rang yes you can
view easy to understand charts and
market data and place a trade in just
four taps on your smart phone damn just
for you can also view stock collections
such as a hundred most popular and and
with Robin Hood you can learn how to
invest in the market as you build your
portfolio
discover new stocks track your favorite
companies get custom notifications for
price movements you're never gonna miss
it man you can invest Robin Hood is
given the listeners King and the sting a
free stock like Apple Ford never heard
of a deal yeah or sprint to help you
build your portfolio you can sign up at
king sting Robin Hood dot-com that is
king
ding Robinhood calm someone's got to pay
for Brennan's coffee habit you know if
you know when you're sell online man
getting your orders can be a real pain
oh yes tough some people get orders and
there's nothing in the box or there's a
hat and they didn't they don't even have
a head yeah it's time-consuming it's
expensive you trying to pick one it's
exhausting man that's why you guys need
to get on shipstation calm yeah
shipstation helps you get orders out
quickly save money on shipping costs and
keep your customers happy no matter what
you're selling Amazon your own website
shipstation brings you all your orders
into one simple interface that's right
Amazon at sea whatever it makes them
really easy to manage from any of any
device and you can manage them on your
cell phone even your cell phone dude
that's how easy is with when we do king
of sting merch we use your ship station
yep ship station works with all the
major carriers including USPS FedEx UPS
even Amazon Fulfillment so you can
compare and choose the best shipping
solution for you and your customer they
even offer big discounts on shipping
cost whatever you need man no wonder
ship station is the number one choice of
online sellers you ship more in less
time with the best rates possible
yep you always know that you're getting
the best deal with ship station no
wonder ship station is the number one
choice of online sellers number one bro
yep you'll ship more in less time with
the best rates available and right now
King the sting listeners can try ship
station free for 60 days when you use
promo code cats that's K 80s there's
absolutely no risk you can start your
free trial without even entering your
credit card info wow that's amazing a
lot of companies won't let you do that
right no if they do just visit ship
station dot-com click on the microphone
at the top of the homepage and type in K
80s that ship station comm then enter
promo code k 80s ship station comm make
ship happen trying to keep the lights on
what else we got chin
do you want to jump in the king of sing
it sure man alright direct this bow bro
just don't snitch on hangers
dang it her first one is from window
buzzers for again just life yeah alright
uhm no name
enjoy it what's up deal getting gay
night boy alright got a king under sing
it for you guys
chubby chasers your opinion on that then
little chicks datin big ol burly looking
guys or skinny guys I don't I don't know
but I mean guys let me wake you the
person running is behind you then you're
the one getting chased bro
okay let me tell you this the
description first of all thank you young
man person in a submission [ __ ] man
and you seem like a good guy opened your
eyes up though a little bit but you
gotta say this though man look us a
small skinny girl dating a big burly man
is a molester bro that is a different
thing the way you described it yeah can
we go to the beginning where he
describes it again chin it's a very
vague instructions very straight yes
let's hear it these confused on just
life it what's up the old gang gang
alright got a king under sting it for
you guys
chubby chasers your opinion on that then
little chicks datin big ol burly okay
stop it down perfectly thin little
chicks our children bucko okay
yeah thin little chicks yeah what do you
use Sanderson farms bro you better with
spacy what is it Picayune Mississippi
but you gotta tighten up man he met with
them a little bird thrown those that
vocabulary out there like that man but
here's the thing man I say there's two
types of everything evens out so yes if
you get a you know a lot of times if you
have more of a Reuben ask woman more
that seventeen hundred's body style then
those women are more sexual more they're
more loving you know you get more you
know they'll be patient they'll hug you
why you why you don't have an erection
you know I'm saying you get a lot more
support they can cook too and yeah and
you got that so you got might have that
snack you might have you know you got
more of a teammate where if you get that
lean Jean you know sometimes you know a
girl that's real to lean it's like you
know like I've said it before it's like
making love to a pillowcase full of deer
antlers or you know bar yeah it's like
sleeping next to a cold crowbar yeah
it's like you some some shelter bro yeah
yeah if you're trying to hug a crowbar
at night dude you're a [ __ ] Wet
Bandits and it's brown from home alone
do you ever hug somebody that's real
skinny bro it feels like you're taking a
test you know I'm saying it's it feels
like third year biology it's kind of it
isn't the same it's not fun it feels
like you're making love to a greyhound
yeah and I like sometimes like you got a
you know you get a little more babe pig
in the city you know when you get that
yeah yeah bird and they're gonna like it
as I call it yeah they're making about
like a pig in a blanket baby yeah so I
think you just gotta think about it you
know there's a doll song I think he
really needs to think about it you know
I'm saying like well he was having a
heat stroke first of all during the
middle of a thing which will be baffling
to me but I say king chubby
yeah I'll say look nothing wrong with a
little extra and we ought to define
chubby cuz your standards are kids which
I don't like to touch on my stand is I I
like curvy woman yeah yeah yeah I don't
mind a woman that has a little bit of
like a an on-ramp you know all right
next one's from Mitch that thigh way you
know what I'm saying I hear ya
that 3-piece [ __ ] dark meat all right
this is Mitch from Fork dude you're like
a [ __ ] gun that doesn't that was not
like test proven by any company's bro
like a bullet
starts coming out of it nears no clue
what its gonna [ __ ] be every time I
get in I'm a musket I'm a musket Brennan
starts a sentence has no [ __ ] idea
where I go throw it out musket I must
get like in here can we take someone
just shot you in the head
aim small miss small son yeah bro okay
your sniper [ __ ] pipe far away boy
this is me you got chin huh what are you
shaking [ __ ] extra rocks out of your
pant leg [ __ ] making chess pieces
together dude okay Brooks was here boy
all right Mitch from Fort Polk Louisiana
oh yeah up in there and Hanako canoe on
Brennan and getting buzz buzz that was
both interesting it for you am i here at
Fort Polk Louisiana
I'm two-wheel hey there's motorcycles
two wheels to heaven baby two wheels to
heaven now
you take a leap people get [ __ ] up on
motorcycles so I it's usually frowned
upon
I have a son I'd never want to ride a
motorcycle I don't want to ride a
motorcycle when I'm in traffic on that
405 and it's dead stop traffic and then
some little [ __ ] rice rocket goes
crew no racers when a [ __ ] rice
rocket goes last a rocket - it's black
guys to Jamaica stop get my private
aliens - rocket you know can us a year
rocket for Brazilians yeah call a rocket
for us straight you know that acai acai
rocket baby so and when they fly by me
and I'm stuck in traffic
yeah dude I want one I'll even jump on
the back and be a [ __ ] really you never
fear feel gayer than when you jump on
the back of a bike and another man's
driving it that's happened to me nothing
if you never felt gayer when you're
going it does give a straw I know when
you go a nuts - but and that power that
motorcycles rocking like this to make
your face like that while you're doing
it on like this and you don't have a
helmet and the winds in your face and
you got a boner going down the 405 I
don't think you're I think you're on a
date it sounds like okay you're right
bro it was it he picked me up I was like
doing hungry like yeah I am and I jumped
on the back of his bike and then we went
a dinner they took me home dude that was
a date ain't nobody on the back of his
bike pay
for a magnet right right yeah dude it
sound like you don't know what's going
on yeah first of all I don't think if
you're holding on to a man on the back
of a motorcycle that has any sexual
connotation I've got it oh yeah I've
done it it makes me feel like I'll have
a strong friend that I can trust and
that can rely on you no it's not I think
it could mean anything it could mean
you're trying to go and save money and
you don't have gas money
the whole time I'm holding on to the guy
I feel like man I'm just glad I'm saving
money on gas weird yeah but yeah if
you're on a motorbike in the 405 that's
that 403 oh boy you [ __ ] fly to that
thing break could be Van Nuys and in
[ __ ] two blinks of a [ __ ] you're like
The Green Hornet doing two blinks of a
large eyeball you could be in [ __ ]
fan eyes but yeah there's something
there's something special about being on
a on a motorcycle and I'm not good at a
man so I don't trust myself on them have
you had one I have I actually won one
one time in a raffle you know could my
family a lot of raffle winners in my
family over the years and and I won one
and I sold it immediately brother they
dropped it off they dropped it off row
and we try to take it down the street
right there yeah I was uh the option to
win won in the last fight ever fun UFC
the winner of that fight response by
Harley Davidson got to pick any Harley
Davidson bike you wanted like a beat up
so I didn't get the bike gang gang yeah
well it happened for a reason though God
went nah give him the bike yeah well I'm
gonna I'm Lee King motorcycles but your
hair looks like you've been on
motorcycles for decades which is crazy
like I'm a grease but I thought the
grease greasers greasers that's right
yeah yeah or just a grease or just
grease yeah use that Chilam now here's a
little time bro you and I are damaged
here bro you're not a damaged route you
know IMS splitting our fall split ends I
do I have some I can see them from here
we are well quit looking accrete what
else we got huh
okay here's the thing man here's what I
what are you doing okay I'm gonna kick
it cuz I like I like it because I'm
jealous um when they go down on those
[ __ ] acai rockets down the middle of
the lane um I'm not good at making
decisions on the fly so
are not good for me however my sister
received was a liver recipient she
received an organ when she was young and
most organ donors are motorcyclists who
died at accidents so shallow motorcycle
yeah but it's a brave move but whenever
you die just know that you guys your
organs go somewhere good I'm gonna say
I'm gonna king him awesome I like that
dude oh he was this guy bro this guy
this chooses canna Coco brush that off
for Pope's son McIntyre and gang
buzz-buzz getting cantor sing it for you
flossing I heard Brenna say you don't
ever floss bro you gotta floss you get
some stinky [ __ ] after them between your
teeth bro you got teeth like Steve Lee
crocodiles for three teeth he's got that
for ya baby he's got that goal line
defense four front teeth two linebackers
in the back everybody up front he's got
that five - boy you don't say Oh dear me
is that wishbone off that's Ron Dayne
there in the distance bro taking that
[ __ ] he has six tailbacks bro you got
you to the wrong place in LA so on up
gang signs you smile like that bro his
teeth throwing up gang signs Oh brah
brought back to 20 you know what
everyone else dude he looks young til he
looks like Dennis the Menace
I'm telling you this broad this dude oh
so he's just saying floss it well let me
tell you this Isana mod whose dad is a
[ __ ] NASA rocket scientist yeah and
mom is a dentist
his mom's like one of the biggest
dentists in the goddamn biggest dam in
the game you know how easy it is to
[ __ ] listen though she said okay he's
an expert homie uh-huh and she said
flossing really doesn't make sense
really yeah
also I don't floss leave his teeth dude
he can floss on my shoelaces dude he's
got definitely it looks like it you know
you could play like a team could have a
good
you could play paintball like with in
his grill he's got that wild grill
brother but that's that bad boy right
there
who cares brought some people
t-that are real straight [ __ ] them son
show em up brah let me see your teeth
I've had you got some work done I've got
some work done yeah Hollywood [ __ ]
hit her well I got there off that fake
front I got the invisaligns a long time
ago
yeah whatever cuz I couldn't eat I
couldn't eat well because I put food in
my mouth and it would come back out you
know when it was cuz I had all these
gaps in my teeth but now I have are they
real is that bone or they Chiclets this
bone baby oh really it's [ __ ] God's
[ __ ] white work son this is an ivory
baby this is enamel so yeah elephant
ivory food if I go to Africa you could I
look behind it because people with a net
right behind me probably back the [ __ ]
off back up bran I get these bad boys
that is cute us and I'll say this right
here we got a beautiful [ __ ] a
Scottish guy right here he'll you know
where he's from you can eat if you have
nice teeth in that country they'll
[ __ ] take you down to a beach in a
brew but bro I'm not even saying you
can't have don't bless Scotland I'm not
mad I don't think from Scotland I'm not
mad at shitty teeth though you know I'm
saying if that's your thing makes you
unique mm-hmm I'll really have shitty
teeth in a [ __ ] up mug oh that's
[ __ ] dummy unique Wilkins right there
then this little guy brought because
that's the most unique dude I've ever
seen what I say floss you gotta floss
man if I take some six hours of fossils
teeth oh it's so easy to floss he could
probably just you know chew on a piece
of string for a couple minutes
that's a good point just like toss a
bunch of [ __ ] string in his mouth oh
definitely man even silly string you can
probably [ __ ] spray a batch of it
into his mouth and get you on a slinky
and I feel like you'd be alright with
those things
I'll King it bro and thank you for the
submission I appreciate you brother
alright this one's from Sofia wax of
Salt Lake City Utah okay Sofia
okay can you uh starting to turn it up a
little bit please driving uh I heard a
woman's voice in a wash oh [ __ ] dude out
of my face I'm chilling you get your
Stanford boner out of my [ __ ] room
don't be okay
further Oh I started over my one more
time yeah are you an angel are you an
angel hey Brendon the deal what's up
girl this is Sofia
okay and I've still Lake City Utah shut
up the Mormons
I had a seer King in question yeah
let's shave their head Betsy you're
busting his back she did it a few years
back
oh let's say for a couple years let me
see I liked it but it's not for everyone
really appreciate you guys love your
content makes my days a lot well you
just made feels better I'm actually
chemist so sometimes I've had hours in
the [ __ ] car bro these pants are hard
in the front material dude they put that
wood in the front
what is that the sexist woman in the
world she's a chemist ji dam what are
you trying to do guys who put her in
here I don't know you trying to make me
feel [ __ ] come in the studio yeah do
we [ __ ] it it's actually a thing on the
wall says we're not allowed to do that
this is no coming dude and I'll say this
would you a chemist what do you mix it
up straight-up bone or saw boner poison
like damn dude one of my ribs just
slipped down into my cry because I went
on to make [ __ ] love cuz I'm plugging
in what are you dying over there you're
a chemist yeah are you an angel damn
voice oh she said it the question what
she wants to shave my head sure sure
whatever you want to do I'll come too
I'm in Utah that's any day now yeah dude
yeah you can shave my head and know what
she wants to and poor [ __ ] acid I'm
here some [ __ ] as a chemist I don't care
whatever you want girl Brenda we'll be
in Utah coming up soon into the WL he'll
also be in I'm not different well I
don't know
he'll also be an all Bama a ll be am a
Britain all times
oh dude Bernake places in America
that's a chemist Oh bro yeah I can't
hear the question look but you can shave
Britney whenever you want Bob Bob
Brennan sheep you can shave me Anthea
yeah
and I actually need to talk in my back
shape so I don't know what your question
is but yes yes genius yeah
you want take my money Wow all right
debate club first one is Brandon Cooper
from Knoxville Tennessee Gang Gang out
of dogs here
what are Brandon you set player buzz
buzz baby that [ __ ] row steel you
need to grow up you need to grow up and
quit watching Saturday morning cartoons
and drink your Pedialyte like a [ __ ]
pedophile Pedialyte is a sexy here it
has different flavors well flavored is
something called big brown black rifle
first of all which sounds like a hate
crime okay okay if you have a black
rifle these days it doesn't sound like
it's for shooting everybody buck oh okay
so if you like that [ __ ] hate crime
hitter then get that black rifle but if
you want something soft that kids will
come around here
Rudy Michael Jackson you know who else
loves Pedialyte if I can Neverland Ranch
that's you had tons of Pedialyte do
where the Neverland ranchers that's what
I want to know you always hear about
Jack so they died
no yeah but where's the guy on the
horseback with a rope you know what I'm
saying that's wrangling these kids
where are the Neverland ranchers the
employees that's a good question
Pedialyte Big Daddy but don't have too
much of it it does have a lot of sugar I
learn that by a lot a ton at the [ __ ]
informed Theo here that he's drinking
all sugar and Pedialyte it's good for
kids if you're a grown man little weird
yeah a little weird I think some sort of
warning to the FBI should come out if
you're buying two or more bottles from
the store yeah don't drink your yarn I
would say drinking indoors it's an
indoor sip or Pedialyte don't drink it
in the yard where people could see you
drinking it because they don't feel the
same way you do about it bro now that
big brown roast oh yeah dude I made that
myself
bro fired them beans up did you really
yeah Wow each batch yeah son now I heard
it's that real hitter people that come
out on the road say that big brown
coffee is good it's legit I just think
the term black rifle is you're focusing
on the wrong thing
you're right that's probably a good
point it sounds like good coffee but
I'll say look man if you do get the
Pedialyte I think they have a sugar-free
version so you can get that day
gone no I drink the real thing you're
gonna drink it [ __ ] King a black
rifle oh yeah
alright your buzzer sounds like a woman
trapped in a well that you hid in the
closet yeah it does
Jesus it sounds like a woman's dunk
contest all right bedroom Martinez I'll
be what I do Rat King and beastie
ashamed son California that debate for
you guys under boob tattoos versus old
school trans tans
well most can be hot some can be not let
me know what you think much love
look I see us Ben I mean dude have you
ever seen a under titty tattoo and not
spike I got a little bit of literature
on the way you lift it up and have a
little Bible sentence or signs like
finding waldo baby just so I can lift
that titty up and boom that nice art
piece underneath the tit there oh yeah
anytime I see listen [ __ ] stamps have
never listened everybody died and you
have one never ever have been cool [ __ ]
stamps have never been cool ever I like
any world I like am I like [ __ ] stamps
because you you see that [ __ ] stamp
you're like oh that lady you know
sometimes it's a coat of arms a fam
familial coat of arms respecting the
family sometime it's a you know a falcon
or something you know you have like no
you write his name too if your
grandfather has a [ __ ] grant stamp on
those Ram stands pretty dope you know
he's got a [ __ ] black rifle on him
you know what I'm saying he's probably a
real Wildcat but I'm saying this man I
think that underboob tattoo man because
it's almost like those Dove chocolate
you know you get those Dove chocolate
and then sometime they put a little
riddle or some words of positivity on
there sometime you live up at it and it
says you know do your best you're
something you know yeah it's almost like
a fortune cookie but of humans yeah you
know when you crack open a fortune
cookie and they give you a nice message
who some girls have that on their tit
well let's go abroad real quick and find
out about fortune cookies can you tell
us a little bit about them
there you go and they are an American
history me dodging racism okay well
sorry
[ __ ] hate cookies I am obviously
racist and I want to apologize to nobody
the legit question
I would've welcomed with Jim you can
learn more with chin though on that well
really Chindi I don't know if chin looks
really like a ethnic to me thank you
thank you I mean it looks kind of older
or younger I can tell sometimes if Shane
is like 14 or like 58 but he looks like
maybe was an entire 50 year old man yeah
good any dresses like swaggy you know so
it's confusing yeah yeah so can we stop
the untrap
definitely not [ __ ] stamp for God's
sakes but if you if you do find a young
lady or man with the [ __ ] stamp you
know you're gonna you got a wild horse
on your hand oh yeah they're growing up
they go neigh no the [ __ ] stamps are
getting bigger that's the problem these
days you know like they're they don't
have them that much anymore I don't I
think that to most tattoo players like
nah we don't do anymore
well it's so lame we're not doing them
let's go - lets go to cat again for the
younger generation are women doing [ __ ]
stamps are you seeing these these days
or is that yeah do you have any tattoos
cat we're under boob side boob boy that
rim under boob that rib boy that's
[ __ ] ribbit ribbit or from--and cat
gots it oh dude [ __ ] then side boob
all day bro I'll go side boob you got a
boner [ __ ] stamp
what's the fancy yeah I forgot to do the
hangover cure one first unbelievable
iron 63% Pedialyte [ __ ] haters they
are headed for sure and the [ __ ] stamps
is eighty six or seven or Sondra moob of
course that's an easy one
yeah and I want to apologize for the
racism but know that it could occur
again yeah it's in your blood though
what else we got a couple pints though
that are a little bit ornery I know yeah
this is forced Morrison from New Orleans
forced mort's up Brennan and Theo this
is Forrest coming at you from Gulfport
Mississippi and I'm a graduate of the
st. Paul school for boys looks like he's
on the Starship Enterprise
from anyway Jefferson still have in Los
Angeles and I'd love to move back but
the problem is that a micro one-room
apartment cost about 1,500 god I saw
Dirt Nasty got himself a little
Winnebago so I started looking at all
this van life stuff on Instagram though
and I ended up copping myself a little
van Oh dela bro as you can see it's got
a nice little kitchen and a couch and it
even has a nice little s hitter in the
back oh that [ __ ] y'all Wow studio
apartment first van look apparently he
doesn't use those tissues on his nose it
doesn't seem like there's a lot of
little sticky icky there's not a seed
milling about in the room um first of
all what's up force he did he graduated
from st. Paul school for boys and
actually had a PDF file back there in
the day
this dude's Langan Stein that used to
work there and he ended up coming over
at our school and tried to uh that
elementary or middle school this was
high school I'm not getting molested in
[ __ ] elementary school like some
[ __ ] loser sorry what I'm saying is
this was later on and um and this man
anyway I know a pedophile from there
okay he came to our school oh damn
that's cool man so anyway connect on
that he was also a cool guy man he took
me to a Marilyn Manson concert oh cool
my first concert ever
Annetta fathered yep and dropped me and
my best friend off there dude he took
one of my buddies to loss maybe even
some more of the story out I don't
remember anything else yeah you know
that's crazy a beautiful people the
beautiful people oh he's just grabbing
[ __ ] dude and that's when uh when
Marilyn cut used a bottle and cut open
his drummer Ziggy or something that the
ambulances came and took him in hospital
cut him up with a bottle right on stage
it's [ __ ] awesome right back when
they really meant it yeah twin brother
[ __ ] his balls
yeah I'd love to see ariana grande
[ __ ] tight and Franky up but yeah let
me see [ __ ] Bruno Mars [ __ ] bite a
bats head you got [ __ ] I'd love to see
Bruno Mars just [ __ ] pipe down
[ __ ] you know Larry Saturn with a
blade or so
yeah like see ariana grande [ __ ]
maybe take a sword to little Frankie
grande out there on stage tighten things
up about that life broke the music real
what was gushing studio apartment versus
van life family bro very [ __ ] light
see that van get your [ __ ] rags cleaned
up though before we jump aboard um I'm
not mad at the micro van yeah I'm not
mad at the microwave once that's that
Simon Rex that's that Dirt Nasty style
man I do think with that van you got
more opportunity to mill about and now
in LA though you always could be in
traffic but at least if you're in
traffic if you get stuck you're at home
but take a nap take a [ __ ] five take
a nap wake up traffic it's gone actually
really a great idea man you live in
Compton you go to the beach if you want
head up north San Francisco yeah you
don't have to go home and take a [ __ ]
you can just [ __ ] and just just floor it
yeah I guess you can think you [ __ ] in
floor it the problem is that when a big
isn't smell like [ __ ] though you know
yeah but if you just throw it on the
windows yeah so mainly I like the micro
van bro you've solved it man you can go
anywhere you want man you're livin
brother yeah you're livin brother and
I'm glad you're taking King in this
thing with you out there man I say what
was the question King the micro vans yes
Kate so you go you pick the studio a
partner or pick a van like van my van
life man all right pick up some lot
lizards on the way audience says studio
apartment 70% eaters eight and they're
trying to stay in one spot I see knock
knock who's there
an advertisement Oh hate to say it you
out y'all dressed me today for the first
time yeah you look good thank you
good man and guess what do you hire
stylist or something my Hollywood
stylist willory man what yep cuz
everyone needs shirts and I got this
swaggy up top hitter you need a shirt
don't you I do man I need one that looks
like that cuz that looks comfortable
fits good even dude is it on tuckable
huh what is happening right now it's on
talkable mint willory shirts are
comfortable easy to care for they look
great and they fit perfectly and guess
what save more when you bundle a man get
$100 strip for $55 when you buy in bulk
you need a bunch of shirts
might as well get ball baby tailored
that means you always look your best
look at you dude you look slim you look
fit you look good
I'm on taco Bowl yep Twitter he has
tailored shirts they send them directly
to you so you just kind of pick out what
you want to like I love it man go ahead
unwind unplug and most importantly on
top that's too short to be all tucked in
and uptight forget that man yeah what's
wrong something I feel so uncomfortable
why someone help me King the sting
listeners be like feel get $25 off your
first shirt by going to twill recom
slash cats and enter promo code cats at
checkout that's twill recom slash cats k
80s and to promo code cats at checkout
that's right
imagine a box of shirts comes to you you
pick out the ones you like and keep them
and send back the ones that you don't
that's Twitter read your swag yeah yep
go to twitter.com slash K ATS and enter
promo code k 80s at checkout time to pay
the bills awesome do you not just use
post mates the other day I use post
mates
everyday bro you're really every single
day Wow
yeah I love post make up illusion your
absolute best friends if you really had
to answer this who would who could you
ask to bring you red wine at 4:00 p.m.
or sushi at 9:00 p.m. that late-night
fish or a breakfast burrito at 8:00 a.m.
dude friends don't ask friends to do
that that's why you hit up post mates
post mates is your personal food
delivery grocery delivery whatever you
can think of delivery service all year
round 365 days that's right download the
app for iOS or Android for free browse
local restaurants and businesses and
track your delivery dude you're watching
that bad fella scoot it on over can't
wait man anything you're craving post
mates can deliver
there's the largest on-demand network in
the known universe with more than 25
thousand partner merchants think about
all the food and now think about it
being in you how's it gonna happen post
mates get it for a limited time post
mates is giving our King in the sting
listeners $100 of free delivery credit
day for your first 7 days
got to eat fast real fast to start your
free deliveries download the app right
now and use code k ATS 2 0 1 9 that's
code k 80s 2 0 1 9 4 $100 a free
delivery credit for your first 7 days
when you download the postmates sap yep
get anything you need anytime you need
it
download postmates and save with code k
80s 2 0 1 9 support the podcast what ok
next one is relationship advice Bravo
first one at this nest or from San Jose
nestor nest without the without Brendan
ganglia buzz buzz buzz buzz relationship
advice because I'm Mexican and come from
a very traditional big Mexican family
and my girlfriend's white and whenever I
go home you know to visit my family I
love to bring her along because I really
want her to grow close to my family and
she does too sure hum however there is
you know the big barrier of language
because my parents don't speak very good
English preach and she doesn't Spanish
you know so Brendon I know your
girlfriend's Mexican and comes from a
pretty traditional family I was
wondering if you guys ever you know face
that language barrier and if so how'd
you guys overcome it thank you guys so
much do see you this week is gonna say
Gang Gang and gang Nestor thanks for
coming out and I hope you had a good
time brother
shut the Nestor because we were just
taping this right after that yes for you
be going ah let me tell you some broad
been with my girl for a hard six ish
years
her family is straight off the boat Sasa
aniele's why I mean straight after why I
mean they jump the wall Mexican you know
I'm saying like real Mexicans all her
family still back there in Guadalajara
and they're here now and listen my house
is like a goddamn I'm a refugee in there
man I'm the only one who don't
understand Spanish I'm sure they're
talking [ __ ] about me so I meant today
no espanol
yeah zero said listen I'm around all the
time I'm talking I'm consumed with
Mexican [ __ ] I got Telemundo on my
goddamn TV it's a relief when I get to
see other white people see and speak -
oh no tongue of English yeah it's a real
gift for me yeah and I'm going crazy at
home man there's almost a cry for help
yeah I don't know Spanish man I've been
around for six years my brain just goes
nah you're too old now also I can't stop
my life and learn [ __ ] Spanish I
think you're like my life and learn
Spanish you don't have to be anywhere I
know I'm dude rosetta stone tried it
nothing you know I learned in rosetta
stone huh nothing boy wait no bueno see
no see he said the other day instead of
nobody said no see Vernon is absolutely
one of a kind
look man son talk [ __ ] to me in Spanish
I think that feels brother
a three-year-old talking [ __ ] to me
going puto what the [ __ ] is he saying
right now quit complaining and help the
guy with this issue
oh here's the thing [ __ ] [ __ ] it just
zone out like I do and slang that dick
bro yeah you know what you do is you eat
that good you you feed her that good
Mexican food and hope she jumps on board
but she doesn't just keep bringing
around just stare off to the ceiling and
eat [ __ ] chili con queso I don't work
out bro look out bro also it's almost
nice cuz they know I don't speak Spanish
so no one talks to me at these
gatherings I speak for a living so it's
kind of nice
no one talks to me I sheet my [ __ ]
queso and my [ __ ] soul Paz and pozole
and I [ __ ] zone out man it's actually
the dream now I say no gringo they say
yeah look man I think it's brave to take
a white person into a fully Mexican
household mannish it sounds adventurous
and exciting also dangerous though yeah
forget that Lee gross oh yeah I want to
be Mexican next time you know I've
already stated that I'm ready I'm 100%
ready and reincarnation and then dude
you were speaking Spanish to my family a
little bit early I loved their
impressive
hey and keep your [ __ ] hands off my
mother-in-law dude I saw the way you
were looking at her at me - yeah
vámanos no senior senior don't they uh
don't ask me my list uh where are my
hands she's very beautiful
okay sorry and that was chin chin don't
don't chime in like that alright what I
would like to say is
good luck out there man I think it's I
think it's it's brave what you're doing
and get that lady in there man you got
that white girl bra bring her in there
teacher the ways brother yeah get a
little whoo yeah get her a little primer
or something a little sheet or something
tattoo or something goes under boob of a
little bit of Education you know teach
her the ways the Mexican ways educator
yeah drop a little culture on her ass
yeah man they drop that case Oh baby
yeah my brother put that [ __ ] brain
salsa in are you feeling me all right
next ones and erupt Nick a bee sting in
the rat King out here asking for some
relationship advice our lovely wife love
her very much
sure from a conservative family yeah
came from the opposite she hates
anything to do with smoking especially
the greenery sounds like real else that
greenery here and there always keep it
away from her in the family that I'm
doing on my own time bro living history
to Athens law and so yeah that's just
don't issue that's always on the Shelf
with us so uh I just kind of him stick
in my ground and she's standing her
grown up you know still not liking it
and I'm still keep doing it I guess we
can't deal with it but yeah it's a I
guess it's an issue relationship issue
so what would you guys do in a situation
like this Cheers
yeah bro dude live your truth bro Oh
suck it in bro sock sock yeah Wow
brother the hell of a pole bro
yeah what sexy you gotta live your truth
man also is your wife of 45 year old
librarian who's not down with marijuana
these days it's legal in most spots also
states they're called points but most
spots you know I'm saying spots brownie
but here's the thing
um are you Cheech and Chong like can you
not live your life like you smoking
non-stop are you [ __ ] Rogen without
the success I'm saying like what are we
doing yeah man it's like uh I don't know
actually what do you think chin and cat
what do y'all think about this one
won't you guys chime in I don't know
idea they don't like it then oh well
don't stop I'm saying is if its effect
if you're showing up to every function
highest [ __ ] you got a problem dude
oh but if you're just if you just
[ __ ] smoking that devil's lettuce at
night and watching [ __ ] scooby-doo
and eating Doritos laughing your alpha
ass off and farting and [ __ ] dude
of your life bro that's called a good
time around from now there is something
special about sneaking off from your
family to do drugs
yeah and I've always thought that man I
used to be a family functions and I'd
sneak off and Huff a little pain or do
whatever we had in the garage mission
impossible don't you oh if I didn't have
weed or something you know or be or I'd
sneak off into the garage and just get a
little bit of a garage hi you know just
huffing whatever was out there you know
it you know stop roll back in and have a
couple pieces of [ __ ] cake and watch
some NCIS with the parents yeah
and that was fun I love there's nothing
more fun than being high around a group
people that doesn't know you are and
then talking to them and continuing to
talk to him well that sounds like a
nightmare for him haver yeah you got
high this week and you tell me that yeah
I got high this week I'm with the
freakin Derek and a son so some brought
us some weed and our hotel was haunted
and I slept with the lights on Friday
night I thought Saturday and I'm sleep
with lights off because grown man quit
being a [ __ ] but then I smoked this
wieners that good Milwaukee [ __ ] oh yeah
[ __ ] fear the deer weed that male we
dude that [ __ ] Greek the Freak weed
hitter I took that thing I got super
scared in my room you didn't sleep very
much at all were you scared of ghosts
yeah do you think OSes him all the
ghosts I didn't get any sleep bro I
could see you being scared of ghosts man
that's fascinating should live its truth
don't they oh yeah look I just think
it's fun to sneak off from your family
and get high so I think doing that as a
[ __ ] hoot
you know keep a little weed in a garage
keep a [ __ ] dime sack out you know
tape it into the top of the mailbox you
know like I think doing something like
that hiding drugs in your car and you
know get copping half a gram while your
wife's in there you know thinking you
just on a commercial break from TV I'm a
bank yeah do that dude I don't have to
having some secret fun is fun and so I
would just keep it a secret though it's
when you have this weird thing where you
need her to know that you're doing it
and you didn't you just creating
controversy so you think just lie and
hide it you're a bad dude no I think you
should just back a [ __ ]
at night I like to smoke some weed yeah
living my life it's not affecting me
we're not doing anything I just smoke in
the back yeah hola hola
pero yo prefiero marijuana
la noche boom hey cami Gio [ __ ] I
smoked some weed is your man smoker do
any drugs yeah tell us about it I just
found out she has a titty tattoo so I
mean I'm looking at got a little
different yeah I didn't know that I know
you asked about fortune cookies yeah
remember that yeah that's what I called
it's bro oh dude [ __ ] Stanford
educators me what are you saying cat you
never done drugs
you ain't livin then what do you mean
not a fan which ones you try
yep just weed yep yeah that's how I
didn't go seek you got that free
hide-and-go-seek with yourself you know
yes it's fun you don't need other
friends PTL baby praise the Lord what's
next Chan alright next one's flying my
aunt and if you guys want to know what
would your fine a say she doesn't make
both you guys like costume I don't know
bro I've seen it though that chinchilla
where she is so happy in Texas oh she
sounds like he's having a tough time
with her man
tell me more I think she would gladly go
on dates with both you guys LT Robbie
and be your uncle bro I'll be in this
town she's not for anything for anything
bro now I'm not into it can throwing her
throwing his hand under the chest over
here you got a shy good I'm trying to
get that beef brisket in San Antonio and
a [ __ ] taste a chant a chant that
bottle back go ah tight no [ __ ] Korean
barbecue in San Antonio a toast these
buns yeah if you guys wanna know details
about them I have a few things I love
some details you see this this is aunt
Cindy [ __ ] yeah she sold tires all her
life she's retired now she posts at
least
pictures a day to Facebook and enjoys
the outdoors and Judson is who the loser
submitted his aunt
shutout to this lady so you know sound
tires any easy job my brother used to
work at a discount tire I worked there
for about two days got fired got my
thing I could see that yeah not much
thing but with her you know would she
win a [ __ ] cannonball contest
probably probably if I had to guess
would [ __ ] murder that contest she
got them Martinelli's boys she's looking
pretty fly think she likes we got that
swaggy one piece on with the dress in
the front looks like she's had some good
years you feel me and that's saying
Cyndi and she's [ __ ] dropping 22s on
[ __ ] thugs and fake thugs around town
and brought hopefully high ball on him
and making a couple extra bucks for
herself you know yeah I hope she has a
pool so that's nice and they got a kid
in the pool and who who is that I see a
little yeah it does look a little Kevin
Spacey back there that's a white Jordan
that's like that crying Jordan mm-hmm
that's a that [ __ ] swimming Randall
zoom in on that swimming Randall chin
let me get him there do that
she looks pretty dope man that's
swimming Randall right things I brought
a ghost this is a really white kid in a
pool why is it just his head where's his
body look I'm glad that aunt Cindy you
know she worked hard and she retired and
she's spending time doing things she
loves she's laying rubber bro Oh shining
that rubber shoe got she won a
belly-flop contest or a cannonball oh
she don't be in the same competition she
ain't afraid to get out there he'll know
I bet she's gettin [ __ ] well they
callin jackknifed another jackknifed
junk ya hear that kids were doing the
pool for you that jackknife [ __ ] that
was dope
yeah I mean I would let her [ __ ] do a
full body flop onto me
oh yeah it's a beautiful lady thank you
Judson is that his name yeah Judson
that's in shout-out to Judson's in all
right this one is grandma Mitsui I don't
trust her she is 85 years old I'll trust
her right now it's in the ice fakes her
heart attacks to get rides and
ambulances and she likes to paint
submitted by Daniel from Maryland shout
out to Daniel
she likes to paint hold up she fates
hold up she [ __ ] the paint she fakes
heart attacks so she can get attention
that's a homeless yeah it's a bit
[ __ ] IVs in [ __ ] meth
he looks um like a
a charming woman she's 85 85 years old
don't you don't know but she still takes
care of herself look at her she's very
she has a you know she's an attractive
look she takes care of brush a flexible
matter she's clearly flexible the way
she's bent down you know both knees are
nice trimming up yes a Filipino squat
they call that yes she also called the
Philly squat they do all like that and
they also if you look at her she's
obviously very you know she's simple to
take care of she doesn't require a lot
she's wearing a Santa hat and also
opening up a bag that has an extra Santa
hat in it you know what now that I look
at this I it bums me out a little bit I
think this kind of a sweatshop scenario
here ones last time saw some we colored
Santa hats she looks scared she has a
whole [ __ ] bag full of different
colored Santa hats it's only in China
where that happens it does look like
dress down Friday too because she's kind
of wearing whatever she wanted but still
doing what's still working dishing out
ones last I saw blue with the [ __ ] do
with the blue Santa hat that's some
Chinese ship at different times bro
times have changed man Santa's painters
seven cents got his own ideas yeah doing
okay she's all right and that's a
grandma not an aunt and thank you for a
mom it's we keep thinking them Santa tax
Corazon violencia that's how you would
say that in Spanish
well thanks dude all right this is Uncle
John and he tried to rob a bank and was
shot several times he's dated several
models in other countries aka he got
catfished and was 100% the person who
took this picture
so John's a liar however pretty awesome
that Da Vinci Code booked he rented that
from the library whether a barcode on
the back that's a great question it
looks definitely stolen because
libraries are closed and he's also using
a selfie stick to take this very
alarming I'm gonna go out on a very
short limb that's not even a limb it's
the truth and say look man if this is
one more troubled stepdad reading the
[ __ ] da Vinci Code and trying to hit
on [ __ ] Russian models on the
Internet they've seen it way too many
times Popeye me a river
yeah and he's got that Paul he you know
he obviously got that Paul Bunyan hitter
he's wearing from the [ __ ] Paul
Bunyan catalog for boys and troubled men
dude also you're batshit crazy you don't
think he's on FBI's most-wanted list
look at this uncle bro he thought it was
like most-wanted like that mean women
want him that's why he got on the list
you just getting catfished every day the
FBI I think the government Facebook
confuse if you don't see wins money all
the time on the [ __ ] Internet if you
don't think this guy's [ __ ] been
wiretap you're out of your mind bro sir
[ __ ] living man he seems like a good
guy man he's getting some rest you know
it's obviously that he's healthy you can
see his arms and no track marks he has a
book in front of him also the other way
to view this it might be the first dead
person we've had submitted read that
it's for my whatever well this is for my
uncle what else you got
alright so that's it is he dead look
he's dead it's the first dead person
without submitting shoutout to dead
people man they're people do you know
yeah them ghost makers baby they got it
you know ghosts have to start somewhere
and they don't start from the Living
Cemetery Alumni shut up to them alright
that's it
oh wow what's up bro not much man I had
a good time to you I had a great time
man I appreciate your services Thank You
Man services yeah you know I'm saying
wrong yeah I don't either
I just know where I'm finally and
that'll hold up or I'm at breath let's
make sure we got the audio on that I'm
in Washington DC this weekend brother
are you I'm gonna watch the only show
not sold out is Thursday Friday Saturday
for show sold out Thursday
get your take his TV a calm and I'm in
Phoenix next month I'm in Phoenix stamp
live were you just there I'm there this
weekend I'll be a stand-up Live Thursday
Friday Saturday and my mom and brother
are gonna come my mom I said what Sammy
tell your mom sort of you what's up yeah
I'll tell her so better with that no she
might know I love that guy we'll see
yeah actually she has I think watch King
and the sting but she said she didn't
want to comment on it is what she said
my mom doesn't watch it because I just
can't yeah but no one knows what I do
so I'm excited about this my and they'll
be in Kansas City the next weekend and
we're at in the Late Show sorry for you
brother on Sunday though right yeah
right in the Late Show on Sunday shadow
stand city on Sunday I'm uh that one out
or not one hour my comedy bit on this
not happening there's Friday stand up
first stand up that people are going to
see they haven't come to my show and a
twenty minute bit into seven so see how
this goes good for you that means you
say there's 13 minutes that people won't
have seen that's good you so much who
drops may 17th though Showtime how come
no quick I know bro I'm nervous
dance well figured out man oh you gotta
[ __ ] start my heart yeah I do have a
start my heart man I got reminded of it
during this episode we had the the young
fella hit in from Fort Polk of their
nearly ville and Anna Coco Louisiana and
I remembered that I went to prom there
they had a girl I met a student council
this girl named Samantha Dewey was her
name Dewey oh dude do we do we do we
love her yes we do you know she was
doing just the most stunning girl I'd
ever seen I met her at student council
on the inscriber she looked like I'm
here to celebrity she had eyes like a
falcon from like the beautycon
no no like a rat like a very wise
beautiful Falco like an Al I have taken
out no like if you had like a fine-ass
Falcon you didn't even believe it was a
Falcon I'm just like a really attracting
blue yes
piercing blue that he's it keep going
bro um she had beautiful eyes and she
had nice hair she had long hairs all her
hair had a dumper on her I don't
remember all that guys when we didn't
have a dumper well the hold on dude so
anyway I went to prom with her man I
went to this small school and I drove
five hours in a borrowed a friend's car
got out there yeah five hours for a
dually with the dumper dude I [ __ ]
Pamela Anderson her prime was I can't
drive five hours and I'll suck you off I
wouldn't drive flat backwards you're
different man now I hear you've come up
bro
don't [ __ ] this is back on five hours of
like 10 hours back when cars only went
about 45
an hour and so super-nice got there dude
and we had a blast when we had a
beautiful just a regular leave her dad
was in the military so they let me stay
at their house the family did but at the
end of the night when we got back home
we had to be home by like midnight and
and the dad let me spend one minute
talking to her in front of him before we
went to before I went had to go sleep in
the room that I was sleeping in dude I
got one minute
tell her what you want to tell her then
get to your [ __ ] room yeah keep your
dick in your pants
oh yeah well there was a snake in the
cages there was nothing profane going on
at all it was killed hmm no no I was
like 15 or 16 man I was young and barely
a gotten even to know my day you know
shout out to her Louie anyway here's
what happened I just found out surprise
yeah I just found out like a month ago
she passed away she passed away from
cancer a couple of months ago I didn't
know about it and but that kid made me
think about it man but she was like the
highlight of my high school was that I
got to go to prom with this beautiful
young lady and I know she had like I she
has a family in Houston and some
children and I was just heartbreaking
here but anyway you know just
remembering her just started my heart so
not where I thought that story's gonna
go I was trying to get to the story like
chill hey Brennan chill on the Dewey
dumper stuff cuz she passed away you get
literally kiss Mike just a little bit I
guess she passed away before you start
making fun of it I try I do give you
know help me out man
and by John Stockton I went recall him
alone dating Dewey give me a [ __ ]
heads up you're over there rebounded
with us I'm gonna shot in the air you're
right bro but give me a heads up well
shout out to do a shout out to Samantha
do we will see you in heaven young like
I see in heaven do we I don't know where
to go from there Jesus I'm sorry I start
my heart I didn't mean it I didn't know
yeah I'm all dis fit my style my heart
was the blind girl from American Idol
shout out to her with one eye doing the
damn thing she had one eye are blind
she's blind
okay no and she's doing it he's [ __ ]
doing it man you know no does she make
it to the next round
I don't know I watched last night her
performance was iffy bad song choice but
she has she's blind in one eye and the
other sketchy it's a foggy and she's
doing it
it's a shout-out to her what's obviously
saying I can't follow this what what
song did she singular the star-spangled
banner' I don't know it was easy [ __ ]
star-spangled she didn't say and I wish
she sunny it was awful dude it was off
why not sing the Pledge of Allegiance
can you [ __ ] make it any easier bro
well here she her name's CheY shut up
Touche American Idol shut up - do we
know I feel like the dick I'll see you
guys on the road I'm sorry I shouldn't
run it up man I didn't know
[Music]